HATED TRUMP AND IT WAS
UNVERIFIED.
REACTION TO ALL OF THIS, AUTHOR
OF "UNFREEDOM OF THE PRESS."
WHICH IS COMING OUT VERY SOON.
HOSTING LIFE, LIBERTY, LIVING ON
THE FOX NETWORK.
I CALL THEM THE GREAT ONE, MARK
LEVIN.
MARK, USED TO BE, YOU WORKED FOR
ED MEESE, YOU ARE HIS CHIEF OF
STAFF.
YOU TALKED ABOUT LONG-STANDING
POLICY OF INDICTING A SITTING
PRESIDENT.
BARR SAID HE HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH IT.
MUELLER HAD NO CONSIDERATION OF
DOING IT.
JIM COMEY, WE KNOW THAT THEY
WERE INFORMED ABOUT THE DIRTY
DOSSIER.
HE SIGNED THE FIRST FISA
WARRANT, HE IS IN LEGAL
JEOPARDY, IRONICALLY, AND NOT
THE PRESIDENT.
>> ALL RIGHT, WHAT OUGHT TO
HAPPEN HERE IS THAT THERE SHOULD
BE A JURY IMPANELED, COMEY
SHOULD GIVE TESTIMONY, AND
McCABE SHOULD GIVE TESTIMONY,
BAKER SHOULD GIVE TESTIMONY.
STRZOK, PAGE, THEY SHOULD GET A
LITTLE BIT OF THEIR OWN
MEDICINE, THEY SHOULD HAVE A
CRIMINAL GRAND JURY AND WE
SHOULD HAVE A SPECIAL COUNSEL OR
A UNITED STATES ATTORNEY TAKE
CHARGE OF THE CASE AND GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF IT.
PUT THESE PEOPLE UNDER OATH AND
LET THEM GET THE DONALD TRUMP
TREATMENT.
WE WENT ALL OF THEIR DOCUMENTS,
NO PRIVILEGES, NOTHING.
DRAG THEM IN AND MAY BE DRAGGED
THEIR KIDS AND TOO.
BUT I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING ELSE, BECAUSE
NANCY PELOSI HE IS QUITE
UBIQUITOUS THESE DAYS.
SHE IS ILLITERATE, BUT THAT'S
THE PERSON THEY CHOSE AS SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE.
AND I GOT TO THINKING SHE IS
VERY, VERY RICH.
SHE IS A MULTIMILLIONAIRE.
I DON'T REALLY CARE ABOUT THAT.
SHE HAS A PERSON, HIS NAME IS
PAUL PELOSI, HE IS A SAN FRANCIS
PAUL PELOSI, HE IS A SAN FRANCIO
PAUL PELOSI, HE IS A SAN FRANCIR
PAUL PELOSI, HE IS A SAN FRANCIS
PAUL PELOSI, HE IS A SAN FRANCIA
PAUL PELOSI, HE IS A SAN FRANCIE
DEVELOPER, A FINANCIAL INVESTOR,
HOW DID THE PELOSIS MAKE
THEIR MONEY?
WHO DO THEY KNOW?
ARE THERE ANY FOREIGN INTEREST?
HAVE WE SEEN THEIR BANK ACCOUNTS
OR TAX RETURNS?
I'M CURIOUS, BECAUSE
NANCY PELOSI LIKE EVA PRALL, SHE
ANNOUNCED THAT WE MAKE THE LAWS
IN THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES,
AND I NEED TO REMIND THE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE, ACTUALLY, YOU
DON'T.
YOU PASS BILLS AND THEY ARE NOT
LAWS UNTIL THEY GO THROUGH THE
SENATE AND THE PRESIDENT SIGNS
ON.
THAT'S HOW THE SYSTEM WORKS.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW ABOUT
ALL OF THEIR CONNECTIONS AND HOW
THEY GOT SO RICH.
I REALLY WOULD.
BUT WE HAVE HERE IS AN ATTACK ON
THE PRESIDENT AND AN ATTACK ON
THE SENATE.
COLLUSION, SPECIAL COUNSEL,
CONTEMPT, OBSTRUCTION,
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
I JUST STARTED WRITING THEM
DOWN.
IMPEACHMENT, TAX RETURNS, BANK
ACCOUNTS, THEY WANT TO.
THEY WERE TO DELETE SOME OF THE
TAX INFORMATION.
THEY ACCUSE HIM OF CAMPAIGN
VIOLATIONS.
THEY ACCUSE HIM OF BEING A
RACIST, ANTI-SEMITE, MENTALLY
UNFIT FOR OFFICE.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT IS GOING ON
HERE.
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY HAS HIJACKED
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES,
THIS IS AN OPPOSITION RESEARCH
CAMPAIGN.
THEY ARE WORKING FOR WHOMEVER
THE DEMOCRAT NOMINEE IS.
IF THEY CAN IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT, THEY WILL IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
BUT THEY ARE TRYING TO DO IS
DRIVE DOWN HIS RATINGS TO GET
THEM UNDER 30%, AND THEN THEY
WILL GO FOR IMPEACHMENT.
OTHERWISE THEY WILL ACT LIKE HE
SHOULD BE IMPEACHED, THEY WILL
TALK ABOUT A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS.
THESE ARE THE TALKING POINTS
NOW.
THEY CREATE THE COMPLEX, THEY
CREATE THE ISSUES, THEY CREATE
THE CONFRONTATION.
THE ISSUE SCORES AND SCORES OF
SUBPOENAS, SIX COMMITTEES.
THE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN AS I
SPEAK ARE MEETING IN DARK AND
SOME SHADOWY ROOM TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO TRY TO BRING
DOWN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES BUT HOW DO I
EMBARRASS HIM TO GO AFTER HIS
BUSINESSES AND HIS SON AND HIS
ASSOCIATES, THEY GO AFTER HIS
COUNSEL.
THEY GO AFTER HIM.
WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF ALL OF
THIS?
OH, WELL, WE WANT TO KNOW IF THE
IRS IS WORKING.
LET ME TELL YOU A SECRET, THE
IRS IS NOT WORKING.
HE NEVER WORKS.
THAT IS NOT AN ISSUE.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS NO FOREIGN COLLUSION.
GREAT, THEN ALL OF YOU MEMBERS
OF THE HOUSE AND SENATE, YOU
COUGH UP YOUR TAX RETURNS IN
YOUR BANK ACCOUNT SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE NOT IN
THE BACK PART OF SOME THIRD
WORLD COUNTRY.
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
FINANCIAL SYSTEM WORKS.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING, IT
WORKS, YOU DON'T WORK, THE DEBT
IS THROUGH THE ROOF.
EVERYBODY CAN SEE THROUGH THIS.
IT IS NOT JUST THE FEDERAL
DEMOCRATS, THEY GET TOGETHER IN
D.C. AND BRING A PHONY LAWSUIT,
THEY HAVE A HOTEL AND FOREIGNERS
STAY THERE, SO HE MUST BE MAKING
MONEY ON THE SIDE.
SUCH B.S.
NEW YORK, STATE TAX RETURNS.
WE WILL PASS AND OBTAIN HER,
THAT IS AGAINST FEDERAL
CONSTITUTION.
WE WILL TURN THE PRESIDENT STATE
TAX RETURNS OVER TO CONGRESS.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT IS GOING
ON.
THIS IS A DEMOCRAT PARTY CABAL
TRYING TO REVERSE THE 2016
ELECTION.
TRYING TO DISENFRANCHISE
63 MILLION VOTERS.
MOSTLY REPUBLICANS, INDEPENDENT,
AND SOME DEMOCRATS, LED BY A
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO, A CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE FROM
NEW YORK, THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE FROM
BALTIMORE.
THREE OR FOUR BLUE CITY IS
TRYING TO CHANGE THE COURSE OF
THIS COUNTRY, TRYING TO REVERSE
THE COURSE OF THE ELECTION.
AND LET ME TELL YOU, THEY KEEP
SAYING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT,
THEY DON'T REPRESENT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY KEEP SAYING THEY ARE
FOLLOWING THE CONSTITUTION.
THEY ARE SHREDDING THE
CONSTITUTION.
THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT IS IN
THE CONSTITUTION.
IT IS WE, WHO ARE STANDING UP TO
THIS CABAL, THIS ROGUE ACTIVITY.
IT IS WE WHO ARE STANDING UP FOR
THE CONSTITUTION.
AND LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING,
THEY ARE PLAYING WITH POLITICAL
FIRE.
THERE ARE TENS AND MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE WHO WILL NOT STAND FOR
THIS.
AND THEY WILL VOTE AND THEY WILL
BE MORE ACTIVE THAN EVER BEFORE,
AND THEY ARE NOT ONLY GOING TO
LOSE THE PRESIDENCY, THEY WILL
LOSE THE HOUSE, WE WILL
STRENGTHEN THE SENATE, AND THEN
MAYBE, AND THEN MAYBE WE WILL
SUBPOENA THE HILL OUT OF THEM.
AND THEN MAYBE WE WILL HAVE
SPECIAL COUNSELS AGAINST THEM.
BECAUSE IF THEY WANT TO USE
SOVIET TACTICS AGAINST
REPUBLICANS, THEN THE ONLY WAY
THAT THE DEMOCRATS KNOW HOW TO
STOP IS IF SOVIET TACTICS ARE
USED AGAINST THEM.
>> Sean: ONE IS A BOOK OUT?
SPEAK OF THE BOOK COMES OUT
MAY 21, PEOPLE CAN PREORDER IT
ON Amazon.com OR ANY OF THOSE
SITES.
>> Sean: Hannity.com TOO.
I GET THE FIRST INTERVIEW FOR
THE BOOK.
WE WILL MAKE THE ANNOUNCEMENT AT